e
[Silence]
for
e e
[Silence]
asalam alaykum
allahar
[Silence]
allahar as
ill as
[Silence]
Asam
Sal
[Silence]
H you
allahar
all
[Silence]
in alhamd
all praise doe to Allah we praise him we
seek his for help and
forgiveness we send sincere peace and
blessing upon the final messenger
[Arabic recitation]
wasam dear brothers and sisters in Islam
we are on the doorsteps of
Ramadan the month of Mer Mercy an
immense spiritual
opportunity the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and his companions
eagerly awaited this month it is
narrated that righteous companions would
pray for months in advance to live until
the next Ramadan and four months after
to have their deed
accepted this shows how precious this
month was to
them we should likewise welcome Ramadan
with joy and
gratitude knowing that Allah is giving
us a chance to raise our sins and draw
us closer to him the prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam
said when Ramadan
arrives the gates of paradise are opened
and the gates of of Hellfire are closed
and the devils are chained
up what a blessed season we are about to
enter a season in which Allah's Mercy
forgiveness and from are abundantly
offered for
believers my dear brothers and
sisters Ramadan is the month of
fasting prayer reading reading the Quran
and
forgiveness Allah says in the
Quran the month of of Ramadan is the one
in which the Quran was
revealed as a guidance for
Humanity and a creel proof of guidance
and
creation so when whomever you witness
the month let him fast
it
fasting is not a ritual of hunger or
thirst it is an act of deep devotion
rewarded by Allah subhanahu wa
taala
in a sacred Hadith Allah says every good
deed of son of Adam is
Multiplied 10 to a 700 times except for
fasting except for fasting it is for me
and I alone were reward for it this
means the reward for sincere fasting is
beyond measure kept with Allah's Bounty
fasting also act as a shield for us
against evil by restraining our physical
needs and desires for the sake of Allah
we train our souls and attain
tawa let me me share with you a powerful
example from the the time of the Prophet
sallallah alaihi
wasallam elating Ramadan
value a companion of the Prophet sallai
wasam narrated a remarkable
dream he knew two men who accepted Islam
at the same
time one of them was very active
one of them was very active in worship
and was killed in the battle attaining
shahada while the second one will Liv to
one year later and had died
naturally so in a dream that he was at
the Gate of
paradise and so both these men standing
there in the dream it was the one who
died later ad admitted first to the J
before the
Shah and tal was
surprised and tal was surprised by that
the next morning he informed the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and his
companions about the dream and the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
explained by
asking did not the second man live an
extra year and witness another Ramadan
and fast and pray the companions
answered
yes the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam then said
between then the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said the difference
between them and reward and rank is the
is is the the the difference between
them in reward and rank is greater than
the difference between the heavens and
the Earth the man who Liv an extra year
which included another Ramadan
of fasting and worship s surp surpasses
even the shahada status
allahar if this is the potential of
Ramadan we must ask
ourselves how can we let such a golden
chance Slips
Away the prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam once ascended to the member to
give
and said
aan
aan three times when asked about this
the the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said jbel came to him and made
three supplications to which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said aan one
of these duas May the person be ruined
who experience Ramadan without gaining
forgiveness foress in other words
someone who lives through Ramadan and
does not secure the has truly lost a
great deal such a person failed despite
all Gates of Mercy are open and shaan
are being chained
up we seek refuge in Allah from being
among the negligent or the losers within
this holy month
in this blessed month our Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam set the best
examples for
us he was always devoted to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala but in Ramadan his
worship reach even higher levels it is
narrated by Abbas that the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam was the
most generous
was the most generous of all people when
he and he was most generous in Ramadan
when jiel would meet him jiel used to
meet with him every night of Ramadan and
they would study the Quran together
during this time the messenger of Allah
sallallah alaihi wasallam become more
generous in doing good than the blowing
wind that brings
that brings rain to a dry
land this Hadith show us two important
things first the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would would review the
Quran every night in Ramadan with
jiel highlighting that Ramadan is the
month of Quran we too should s sit aside
time to study recite and reflect on the
Quran as it is the guidance revealed in
this this holy
month the second important thing the
prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
charity and kindness in Ramadan was
unparalleled as a free as a wind that
brings rain to the dry land he gave
abundantly in charity fed the poor and
showed extra generosity in
Ramadan following his Sunnah this is the
best time for Sak for helping those who
are need and for showing generosity in
all
forms the
Companions and early
Generations imitated this
passion for
example
ABD was known for his compassion in
Ramadan
it is stated that he would only break
his past in the company of a
poor he used to give to in charity
whatever he could even something sweet
he enjoy eating saying he had heard
Allah's word you will never attain
righteousness until you spend from from
which you love you will never attain
righteousness until you spend from which
that you
love the companions understood that Fe
that feeding others and giving charity
in Ramadan carries a huge
rewards the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in a Hadith once
said whomever gives AAR to a fasting
person will have a reward him
without reducing the reward of the
fasting
person so every Act of generosity in
this month multiplies our rewards and
spreads our
blessings the examples of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and as his
companions are
inspiring think of the Prophet sallallah
alaihi wasam is standing long night in
prayer
making Dua to Allah for his
think of the companions
and Tam reciting Quran in such a
way that they couldn't get past one
verse for a long
time think of the poor and
hungry Ramadan transform
Hearts Ramadan transform
Hearts We should strive to taste a
portion of that that
sweetness We should strive to test a a
portion of that sweetness of of of Faith
throughout our worship and Good
Deeds motivation alone is not
enough we need a practical plan to
utilize every moment of Ramadan
wisely time in Ramadan is M melting
ice
block if you do not shape it with a PL
with a plan it will slip away it will
slip
away so here are five tips to help you
maximize the spiritual benefit of
Ramadan
inshallah the first
one is begin with with a sincere
repentance enter Ramadan with a clean
heart even before the month
starts repent to
Allah repent to Allah for past sins and
make amends with anyone you have
wronged a heart free of grudges and sins
is more receptive of blessings the
prophet sahu alaihi wasallam said oh
people repent to Allah for I Repent to
him a 100 times a
day the second
step set to clear intentions and
goals plan what you want to achieve
spiritually for
example intend how many times you will
read the Quran or how many pages per day
how much charity will you will give and
which habit you want to
change write down a proposal a list of
of Ramadan goals praying every
prayer on
time never
missing and reading the Quran for 30
minutes
daily the third
step protect the past from sins
fasting is not just from food and
drink but also refraining from sinful
speech and
behavior be extra mindful of your tongue
your eyes and your ears no
backbiting no Veil talk talk or no
viewing of Haram content the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said if
someone fights you or insult
you while you're fasting
respond I am
fasting meaning do not engage in any
arguments good manners and and and
Patience are part of
fasting the fourth
step make the Quran your
companion this is the month the Quran
was sent down so honor it by by reading
as much as you can every
day if you struggle with reading use
this month to improve your
recitation Allah rewards every effort
perhaps read a juo or a part of a each
day to complete the Quran by the end of
the month which is a common and notable
Target if that's difficult set a
realistic portion and stick to
it reflect on the
meanings read t for for a few verses
each
day and the last
step moderation in approaching
D to
maximize spiritual
productivity be moderate in your
approach to Dunya and worldly life
during
Ramadan do not overindulge in AAR meals
Ting can make you lazy for pray in
prayers our companions kept it simple
remembering the purpose of
fasting enjoying Halal Delights forar
and sahur but do not make food the focus
of the month do not make food the focus
of the
month additionally avoid turning nights
into social Gatherings that make you m
or stay up
gossiping strike a balance so you that
your body is nourished and your soul is
a free for
worship these five
steps beginning with a sincere TBA
setting a clear intentions and goals
protecting the faster from sins and
making a Quran your companion and
moderation in approaching D during
Ramadan if we follow these steps
inshallah you will make the most of
moment in
Ramadan remember consistency is a
key start strong from the first night
and first day and if you fell or fell
short or slip on one day do not give up
do not give up each day is a new
opportunity keep renewing your
intentions and rely on Allah's help and
make
Dua dear brothers and
sisters let us not forget
those who were with us last year Ramadan
but no longer here this
year many Souls have returned to Allah
since last
Ramadan we pray for their forgiveness
and
mercy we have been given another
chance we don't know if we will live to
see another
Ramadan so treat this Ramadan as
possibly your
last we might think we have long lives
but we truly don't know
the opportunity is now Ramadan is our
chance for
forgiveness do not hesitate in doing
good
change should start from the first day
of Ramadan in fact from now as we
prepare for
it we ask Allah to grant us the life to
reach Ramadan and the ability to worship
Him in a best way during it
[Silence]
ald servant of
Allah I remind myself and you of the
command of Allah to have
tawa in all
circumstances
Tonight
Tonight Ramadan will begin
inshallah Ramadan Mubarak my dear
brothers and sisters may Allah accept
our our Deeds
inshallah let's take advantage of these
remaining hours to prepare ourself
mentally and
spiritually resolve any pending
arguments forget forgive others so Allah
will forgive you and start Ramadan with
a clean
slate
remember the essence of Ramadan is not
fasting from food but also training in
ourselves to obey Allah and avoid
sins the true essence of Ramadan will be
judged by how much we improve in our
obedience and character even after the
month
ends so intend not only to Worship in
Ramadan but to carry its lessons
forward if you avoid backbiting and
laziness for 30
days there's no Reas reason to return to
it once shaal
comes let Ramadan be a launching path
for a permanent change towards a better
IM and
practice in these blessed days increase
your Dua for yourself and the umah our
word is in desperate need for mercy of
Allah there are those suffering in war
poverty and oppression remember them in
your prayers
when you feel hungry and
thirsty while fasting let it remind you
of the hunger of the poor and
refugees and soften your heart to give
and pay to give and pray for them we are
a one body as
Muslims oh Allah the most merciful we
thank you for the gift of Ramadan we
have not worshiped you as you deserve
but you but your mercy is greater than
our
shortcomings allow us to reach Ramadan
and fast its days and pray at nights
with e andas Ya Allah enable us to take
full advantage of each
Ramadan Inspire us to the best of deeds
and keep laziness and distractions away
from us help us remember you and recite
your book abundantly make the Quran the
spring of our hearts Ya Allah forgive us
forgive our sins the major and the minor
the past and the reent cleanse our
hearts and feelings for on our bodies
and habits of of sins let this Ramadan
be a means of complete forgiveness and
purification for each of us y rman have
mercy on the of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam relieve the
distress of Muslims who are are
oppressed or un hardship feed the hungry
and heal the
sick throughout our fasting and Dua
bring unity and peace to the Muslims and
guide us back to the your straight path
oh Allah guide our youth oh Allah guide
Our Youth and protect them from
Temptations bless our elders with good
health and strong faith reward our
mothers and fathers and have Mercy on
them as they raised us
[Silence]
muh
forar ill
[Silence]
allahar alhamdulillah
must
[Silence]
in
Sal
[Silence]
all
all alhamdulillah
Al
[Silence]
n
sh
[Silence]
all
all for
[Silence]
Salam
alikum brothers and
sisters it's very important for me to
share with you some of the announcements
today so please take a note of some
of these because it's very important for
us to to start the Ramadan and with the
great blessings but the same time we
also have to take care of some matters
with the neighbors inshallah
so
first inshallah there's going to be a
change in timings for the for the
prayers starting tomorrow morning the
fud prayers prayer will be at 6:00
a.m. and the ass will be at 5:00 p.m. so
basically we're going to have a special
schedule throughout the Ramadan so
please make sure that you are aware of
these timings fud is going to be 6:
a.m. will be 5:00 p.m. that's the AMA
times and Isa is going to be 8:00 p.m.
inshallah we definitely we have we need
your help in making sure that we are
able to fulfill the afar calendar that's
posted back there if you cannot you know
there's a 2,000 for the weekday and
3,000 for the weekend so if you want to
split it with somebody else please put
your name up there and put partial or P
next to it and leave your number so
we'll coordinate that
inshallah this is the most important
announcement I want to make today so I
was just waiting to to get to this it is
the neighbors are going to be having
their own set of activities as you know
that we have been using their parking
lot for our activities and we have been
they have been very generous with
us this week they have their own
convention so I'm going to request every
one of you personally to please help us
there's something else all also
happening they have been doing some
repairs to their parking lot so of
course that is nearing completion but
their convention
starts it's actually it's Thursday
Friday Friday and Thursday Friday and
Saturday so it is 700 p.m. every night
so we need to make sure our vehicles are
not in their parking lot or in the way
so we cannot just say just because it's
vacant or I can see a lot of space I can
go park please do not do that we'll have
our people to to help you coordinate
the traffic at least for our
activities we have a lot of parking
spaces in the you know the neighbors
have a parking spots in their backyard
so we can use that also there's a
parking along the street and the parking
in the at the end of this this this
street that there's a ample parking so I
think inshallah we'll be able to manage
all the the traffic today but we need
your cooperation and look for the
direction that people are providing you
and be kind to your neighbors
inshallah we will be also doing some
fundraising during the month of Ramadan
and will announce that with the for the
specific purpose but I'm going to
request you every Friday to just take
few minutes to do not schedule a meeting
right after that that you have to say
assalamu alkumah and run out of here
that's something that will help us at
least get everybody participate and if
you cannot you know just make sure that
you are able to help us in maintaining
some discipline and some coordination
inshallah thei inshallah the the
recitation is going to be led by H Assam
I saw him here can you raise a hand
please there's brother Assam back there
and brother Dari they will be leading
the Tavis inshallah and there is
there's one other announcement there's a
science project there is
announcement going to be who the winners
are so if you have time to just go by in
the gymnasium and you'll you'll be
able to participate in that
again please contact me or brother
jabber for anybody who wants to donate
or participate in
theam Alik
[Silence]
sh